les jeux c'est une fois tous les 100 ans
on va accueillir le monde on va être
regardé par des milliards de personnes
on doit montrer le meilleur de notre
pays
waouh ça fait plaisir de revoir ces
images là
[Musique]
l'euphorie de la délégation française
après l'attribution des JO 2024 à Paris
[Applaudissements]
cette victoire il le savent il la doit
vont partie à un homme Tony Estanguet ce
triple champion olympique de canoë qui
semble devoir être oréolé de succès dès
qu'il s'engage dans une compétition
c'est vrai que c'était une sacrée
compétition quand même celle là
quand on s'est engagé dans cette
aventure tout le monde nous disait mais
non on sait pas faire les Français ça
fait cinq fois qu'on perd de suite la
France elle sait pas gagner ce genre de
compétition on est nul en lobby on est
nul en je sais pas quoi
et voilà on l'a fait quoi on l'a fait on
a relevé ce défi on a ramené les jeux
dans notre pays et c'est vrai que
c'était
c'était quand même une belle aventure
humaine pour moi c'était fort parce que
pendant 20 ans j'ai passé ma vie dans un
canoë un peu seul à relever des défis
sportifs mais dans un sport individuel
même si on est voilà il y a toujours un
entourage
là ce que j'ai adoré dans dans cette
phase là de candidature c'est que ça a
été une petite équipe là très soudée et
on est allé chercher cette victoire
ensemble c'était magique qui a porté un
regard je pense un peu différent un peu
nouveau moi j'avais envie qu'on parle de
sport c'est pour ça que on a créé une
équipe avec beaucoup de sportifs
beaucoup d'a hlètes qui sont venus il y
avait Teddy Riner on a vu Michael
Jeremias avec le micro là qui chantait
allumer le feu voilà donc c'était une
équipe vraiment soudée et on est allé
convaincre le Comité international
olympique que le sport français avait
ses chances et que ces jeux auraient de
la gueule et on m'a su alors démontrer
que il fallait justement nous attribuer
ces jeux
[Musique]
malgré son jeune âge 22 ans Tony ne va
pas céder son sens de l'attaque va faire
la différence dernier à passer dans
chaque manche il s'impose d'une seconde
la pression et le vent qui balaye les
piquets n'auront pas troublé le nouveau
qualifié olympique à 27 ans Patrice
estanguy doit accepter la supériorité de
son frère sans faute sur cette deuxième
manche c'est pour deux secondes au total
que son aventure pour Sydney s'arrête
après deux ans de préparation cette
fois-ci ce sera moins
la dernière fois j'étais derrière la
télé je j'étais comme une comme un fou
pour pour lui et vraiment j'étais super
content qu'il remporte la médaille ce
coup-ci je vais y aller et j'espère que
je vais pas y aller pour rien c'est ce
jour-là que je suis devenu finalement un
sportif de haut niveau j'ai ça faisait
plusieurs années que j'étais sur le
circuit que j'étais un peu dans l'ombre
de mon frère qui était mon exemple voilà
mon mentor c'est mais le jour où il a
fallu
éliminer le grand frère pour prendre la
seule place disponible pour aller aux
Jeux Olympiques
je peux vous dire que ça a été
ça a été une délivrance aussi parce que
il a fallu accepter que j'étais plus le
petit dernier de la famille et
dans ces moments-là
émotionnellement psychologiquement
c'est très fort ouais c'était très dur
c'était très dur c'est violent c'est
violent on est c'est pas normal
finalement de
devoir avoir cette relation fratricide
avec en étant adversaire et et voilà on
est passé par des émotions difficiles
parce que je pense que tous les deux ont
rêvé de cette victoire et de ce titre au
jeu je pense que Patrice mon frère il
était à ce moment là favori pour les
jeux de ciné je me souviens très bien
des moments où il a dit écoute là c'est
tendu il vaut mieux que on s'entraîne
non plus tout le temps ensemble mais qui
est des moments où chacun s'entraîne
dans son coin donc c'est une histoire de
famille voilà on va on nous voit là tous
les cinq
mes parents et mes deux frères et on
avait de belles de belles polaires
d'ailleurs dans la famille
[Musique]
si vous voulez si je vais trop vite
derrière la tête du gendr idéal se cache
un caractère bien trempé même pour rire
il y a des choses avec lesquelles on ne
plaisante pas la défaite par exemple
depuis ce jour-là
il n'existe aucune preuve à cette course
et en plus
impossible
j'ai quand même des doutes sur cette
histoire là mais mais c'est vrai que je
suis compétiteur non je reconnais je
suis compétiteur et c'est comme ça que
j'ai été élevé aussi que j'ai grandi et
j'aime pas perdre j'aime pas perdre
effectivement là on voit les images de
Pékin en 2008 où j'étais double champion
olympique sortant il y avait voilà une
grosse attente j'étais port drapeau puis
et puis de même pas se qualifier pour la
finale je termine les neuvième on vient
de le voir là on le voit pas à l'écran
parce qu'en fait c'est vraiment une
toute petite touche sur la porte 3 où
j'ai le bateau qui pour aller un petit
centimètre bien frôler une porte et donc
j'ai une pénalité ce qui fait que ça me
sort de la finale et
mais le sport au niveau c'est ça aussi
c'est apprendre à perdre ça a été une
vraie leçon d'humilité je pense que je
serai peut-être pas en face de vous
aujourd'hui si je n'avais pas perdu à
Pékin
[Musique]
depuis quelques jours son nom circulée
avec insistance dans les couloirs du
sport olympique français ce matin Tony
Estanguet à savourer cette nouvelle
récompense en août prochain à Pékin il
portera le drapeau d'équipe de France
très apprécié des autres sportifs ce
professeur d'éducation physique fait
l'unanimité
autre chose c'est pas que le palmarès
cette reconnu par ses pères sur le fait
que quelque part on incarne le sport
français on est un bel ambassadeur du
sport français et c'est une émotion là
on a vu là sur les images des David
Douillet Jackson Richardson au premier
plan et tous les autres mais voilà quand
on met son nom dans la continuité de ces
très grands champions
voilà on se dit waouh quand même c'est
des athlètes qui m'ont fait rêver et
finalement mon nom se met à la suite de
ces grands champions moi je me souviens
vraiment dans le dans le tunnel du stade
avant d'entrer dans le stade au moment
de la cérémonie d'ouverture les 300
athlètes français qui étaient derrière
moi qui ont commencé à chanter la
Marseillaise parce qu'il devait sentir
que il y avait une émotion forte quand
même
j'ai eu la chair de poule je me souviens
très bien de ce moment là et puis on est
entré dans le stade ensemble on a fait
ce tour du stade
voilà pour un athlète du canoë-kayak de
se retrouver dans un stade de 80 000
personnes avec plus d'un milliard de
personnes qui regardent à la télévision
et porter le drapeau français c'était
l'un des plus beaux moments de ma
carrière
[Musique]
et décidé de mettre en terme à ma
carrière internationale aujourd'hui
allez il y a un petit vide là
c'est pas facile
parce que c'est bon d'être sportif de
haut niveau
[Musique]
bah le jour où j'ai prononcé ces mots-là
pourtant c'était encore une fois
mûrement réfléchi depuis longtemps
je me souviens j'ai le corps qui s'est
cristallisé qui s'est bloqué j'arrivais
plus à parler et il y a une émotion
forte quand même c'est
si on peut pas tout contrôler dans la
vie c'est beau je trouve de pleurer
d'avoir des émotions de les partager il
y a aucune honte au contraire je me suis
rendu compte dans ma carrière que les
moments où qui ont été les plus intenses
et les plus forts c'était des moments où
il y avait du lâcher prise quand on est
dans le Start ni finalement olympique et
un instant où il va falloir se dire ok
j'ai bien bossé ça fait quatre ans que
je m'entraîne deux fois par jour je sais
faire mais je vais être confronté à des
à des imprévus il va falloir que je
lâche prise et c'est grâce à ces moments
là aussi que on se fait rattraper par
les émotions et qu'on va chercher au
fond de soi des des ressources c'est ça
qui m'a fasciné dans ma carrière c'est
c'est mon moment de manière complètement
irrationnelle j'ai réussi à faire des
choses que je n'avais jamais réussi à
faire à l'entraînement et je savais pas
l'expliquer et voilà et ces moments là
et je trouve que aujourd'hui je continue
à m'appuyer dessus parce que que il y a
que le sport de haut niveau qui m'a
appris à dépasser ça je sais que le
sport a changé ma vie et qu'on a besoin
aujourd'hui que le sport français
continue de jouer ce rôle là dans la
société
[Musique]
cela devait être une grande fête du
football
elle a tourné au fiasco
on a payé pour être là j'ai un ticket
le match c'est longtemps joué à
l'extérieur du stade entre ceux qui
tentent d'enfoncer les grilles et des
policiers qui répliquent à coup de gaz
lacrymogène
ouais c'est triste c'est triste d'en
arriver là c'est tellement éloigné de de
ce qu'on rêve de ce qu'on de ce qu'on a
imaginé depuis si longtemps et je faut
garder beaucoup d'humilité parce que
voilà ces images là elle date de pas
très longtemps on est très aujourd'hui à
l'écoute de tous ces signaux de dérive
potentiels on a décortiqué tout ce qui
s'était passé ce soir là pour essayer de
comprendre pour essayer de d'éviter de
reproduire des erreurs qui ont pu être
commises en fait là la je pense que la
raison principale c'est que c'est un
match qui s'est organisé un peu au
dernier moment qui était pas prévu
d'être organisé en France
et du coup il y a manqué de préparation
il y a eu des décisions tardives qui
n'avaient pas été réfléchie qui n'avait
pas été anticipé
c'est un manque d'anticipation c'est un
manque de coordination on l'a vu aussi
ce qui a
les difficultés c'est un lien aussi avec
les systèmes de transport
donc voilà il y a un certain nombre de
d'enseignements qui ont assez précieux
pour nous
et on va voilà faire en sorte que ça
n'arrive plus notre responsabilité c'est
de rester très ambitieux les jeux c'est
une fois tous les 100 ans on va
accueillir le monde on va être regardé
par des milliards de personnes on doit
montrer le meilleur de notre pays
[Musique]
19 secondes 8 dixièmes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça c'est un vaste sujet
c'est un vaste sujet effectivement on
l'a vu effectivement à plusieurs
reprises
ces expressions personnelles c'est
c'est normal entre guillemets les
athlètes c'est d'abord des citoyens
c'est d'abord des hommes et des femmes
qui ont envie de
voilà d'avoir pour certains d'entre eux
ce côté militant pour des causes
auxquelles ils croient
mon rôle l'entend qu'organisateur c'est
aussi de préserver un espace sportif
qui ne partent pas dans tous les sens
pour toutes les causes parce que c'est
difficile aussi de préserver ce qu'on
aime dans le sport de haut niveau dans
le sport de compétition c'est que c'est
un espace justement neutre
un peu apolitique où on est là pour
partager un moment de sport des émotions
sportives les temps de sport les temps
de podium sont des moments solennels
il est temps en amont et en aval juste
après notamment sur les conférences de
presse où les zones mixtes ou tous les
journalistes peuvent poser toutes les
questions qui veulent aux athlètes là
les athlètes s'expriment comme ils le
souhaitent c'est une question difficile
aujourd'hui de savoir est-ce que les
athlètes russes peuvent courir avec leur
drapeau doivent être complètement exclus
de des jeux et donc de trouver cette
possibilité d'une participation sous
bannière neutre c'est à dire sans faire
la promotion de leur pays sans qu'on
voit leur drapeau sans qu'on voit sans
qu'on entend de leur hymne
mais que l'athlète encore une fois
puisse lui participer à cette
compétition je trouve que c'est c'est
acceptable
[Musique]
ces scènes ne sont pas rares un
journaliste britannique a même piéger
les membres de la fédération
azerbaïdjanaise en train de revendre des
tickets obtenus gratuitement
l'image a écœuré les fans de sport
autrement car depuis le début de la
compétition on distingue clairement
dérangé de siège désertés dans les
stades cet anglais a cherché pendant des
mois des tickets pour son fils fan
d'escrime peine perdu
on en passera par là mon fils a 7 ans
les jeux sont dans son pays et il ne
peut pas y assister
ouais c'est difficile de voir ces images
là parce que bien évidemment on rêve
tous d'une fête populaire d'une fête
accessible
c'est le plus grand événement sportif de
la planète il y a une attente aussi très
forte malheureusement on ne peut pas non
plus satisfaire ses attentes parce que
il y a des dizaines de millions de
personnes qui voudraient assister au jeu
vivre les jeux et même si c'est le plus
grand programme de billetterie avec
13 millions de billets en vente il y
aura beaucoup déçus plus de déçus que de
gens qui ont réussi à acheter des places
c'est comme ça
on fait tout pour limiter ces risques de
de corruption de marché noir mais la
nature humaine fait que il y a des
petits malins qui arrivent toujours à
trouver des failles donc on essaie de
réduire tout ça pour que le système soit
le plus efficace possible
[Musique]
on a un client important donc je compte
sur vous pour que ce soit
particulièrement en face une belle
soirée
excuse-moi tu peux prendre le plateau de
la cuisine
tu es sûr de toi là pour les feux
d'artifice
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je vous ai dit j'ai dit on
se coordonne il y a personne qui
comprend que je joue ma vie moi à chaque
soirée je joue ma vie Jean-Pierre Bacri
quel acteur
non non non je suis pas ma vie du tout
je sais d'où vient je sais où je vais je
sais ce que voilà ce que je peux
apporter à ce projet mais c'est vrai que
ce film voilà je vois que vous avez été
bien renseigné c'est un slim qui m'a
touché qui m'a fait rire il y a
d'ailleurs dans les paroles une formule
qu'on a beaucoup repris c'est on
s'adapte parce que Jean-Pierre Bacri
dans ce film là il n'arrête pas de dire
en permanence quand on organise en
mariage on s'adapte mais je peux vous
dire que quand on organise les jeux on
s'adapte parce que tous les jours il y a
des imprévus et donc oui on va s'adapter
on va trouver des solutions donc voilà
c'est un film qui qui m'a fait sourire
et on l'a on l'a partagé avec les
équipes parce que c'est assez semblable
[Musique]